[Music]
Luke dominate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we are
starting our 2018 world tour well guys
I'm doing something that I've wanted to
do for a long time I've taken a month
off of work and we are going to pretty
much travel the world I have 29 airline
tickets and we are going to be going
crazy we've got some amazing things
planned and I'm gonna bring you guys
along for the ride are you guys excited
to do our world tour yeah
the first challenge we have for this
world tour is getting everything a
family of five needs for a month into
these bags here and we are doing it we
have been smart we're packing light
we're staying organized we're gonna do
this thing
holy mackerel look at that pile of
luggage
[Music]
before going on this big trip we got TSA
PreCheck we're gonna give that a try for
the first time hopefully that will help
us avoid that massive one over there to
make things a little bit easier let's
see how it goes
we're really lucky we got the TSA
PreCheck for the whole family because if
we had we would have missed our flight
the Super Shuttle was an hour late
picking picking us up and the line for
security was enormous and because of the
pre-check we got through in about five
minutes still is hectic but at least it
was shorter they're going to go on dump
their plane it's going to be some
awesome time
we made it we're live we're here
[Music]
our pleasure to welcome you to Salt Lake
City or the local time at 7:55 p.m.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't get that one I should I think we
have six
all right Tommy we made it to Salt Lake
City but are you excited
glad to see grandma grandpa awesome it's
gonna be off the hook Shelly off the
hook
all right we're here
those kids wake up early so Tommy and
Nathan we're up at 5 a.m.
which is like 7 a.m. their time so they
just got up like they normally do and I
am so exhausted because we stayed up way
too late
eating and talking and I think we're
just gonna take it nice and easy go go
visit a relative drive around a little
bit look I am crushing your head
crushing your head put your gloves on
it's nice just to have a relaxing lazy
Sunday morning Nathan are you ready for
church Tommy are you ready for church
yeah oh oh yeah that is one cute baby
look at those little cake boobies like
daddy
lovely so I think it's time to go to
church what do you think all right there
look at those little shark shoes that's
the stuff right there
nice easy relaxing day did you have fun
at church what did you do at church are
going to do five years so this will be
nice to see him and get him to see the
kids he hasn't met Nathan and Jacob yet
so we're gonna do that a little two
hours each way I think and I have the
smallest seat ever created
at least I got plenty of legroom I mean
that's something you got plenty of
legroom Tom yeah you do
well there's both of the Idaho our
second state in our well guys we made it
but oh my back is sore
we're here in Downey Idaho population
620 you're the big ones Tommy a little
Jacob what are you complaining about
we're back in the car and we're taking
the indirect route back to Salt Lake
we're to suite by an old like the stores
ghost town pioneer town called
Chesterfield here in Idaho so we're
gonna check that out
so we're out in the middle of nowhere
here in Chesterfield Idaho it's an old
pioneer town a ghost town of sorts and
people have taken each of the old houses
and just kind of built them up repaired
them one by one and vampires here and
ghost ghost town means there's lots of
ghosts yeah check it out this is the old
tiding office so back in the days of the
old pioneers they used to pool all their
money and resources together and
distribute it out I check it so you guys
can see that inside it's restored too
they have the old stove and they got the
picture of the Prophet Joseph Smith and
the Prophet Brigham Young over there in
the corner yeah is that cool yeah so me
and Tommy want to hop in and out look at
all the different houses but it's too
much work get me in and out of that seat
so we're we're tailgating at this point
Tommy
when me and Becca you see you live in
Utah we bought a book that we had a list
of all the different ghost towns in Utah
and that was our thing for like a summer
or two we just go and look for each
ghost town and visit him there's tons of
them all throughout the West here but
this is actually probably one of the
biggest ones I've ever seen so
apparently this town was one of the many
towns along the Oregon Trail so
hopefully none of us will die of cholera
[Music]
[Music]
oh cool
[Music]
I was in the fourth grade I bought one
like this for 10 bucks this right there
that's a chamber pot that's for pooping
row at the middle of the night if you
need to use the potty you don't want to
go out to the outhouse you use the
chamber pot right there so you're on
point that's the potty wanna go check
out the potty cool thing about this
place is it's the family's the ancestors
of these original pioneers that are
fixing this up and restoring this entire
town this isn't a park or anything this
is just people preserving history Oh dad
that's the potty look there's another
shed right there that's the log Kent
logs from a log cabin the interesting
thing about is how spread out this is
there's there's an old cabin out there
there's old cabin up there
there's another one there you can see
there's that house that house that's the
tithing house there's my sexy wife
there's more cabins over there and then
there's lots of ones that have just
rotted away like there's a little cabin
right there check out this old farmhouse
they've got an old-timey crane for
loading up hay right there
this is how the Pioneers got their gas
hogan's the calls Jenson's all people
used to live in the town Butch Cassidy
man actually butch Cassidy's got his
roots in Utah I think his family was
Boorman or something like that but
apparently he stole the horses of the
guys that founded this town
all right guys hold on tight there's a
lot more fun than riding on the inside
of the car yeah check this out this is
old dugout cabin here got the outhouse
in the back cobblestone they dig into
the hillside like a hobbit hole then you
plant grass on the roof come out come
back here guys get away from the
sprinkler you want to ride in the back
all the way back to Salt Lake that's not
happening downstairs take off your shoes
way past your bedtime stay three and
we've got some exciting things planned
today when I asked Nathan what he wants
to do for breakfast and he says be poopy
and eat eyeball soup I think I better be
the one calling the shots for breakfast
today all right so we're gonna get
ourselves some fun breakfast at a place
called the original pancake house not to
be confused with the non original
pancake house small chain here in Salt
Lake County so anywho here we go let's
do this
apparently they need a silo here at the
pancake out all right guys we got a ton
of food let's take it back to the house
and get eating I'm hungry
that's the sausage got losing the fresh
fruit crepes
we got the fresh fruit french toast
buckwheat blueberry pancakes bacon
waffles we got fruit pancakes and then a
bunch of baked our sausage you like that
I always pretty good huh yeah look at
that doesn't that look good well you
need to go pick up some fishing gear you
guys want to go in the fishing store
let's do it that pretty cool guys will
you help me pick out a fishing rod it's
not a bad choice actually look at this
yeah that's a really cool net but it's
it's worth a hundred and sixty dollars
so I don't yeah I don't think we're
gonna be grabbing that one anytime soon
ooh anchovies minnows sucker me ooh they
got chubs are you guys excited to go up
to the cabin
[Music]
there we go we're going to the cabin you
guys so Becca tells me right now that
the scenery is really gorgeous
oh well here we are this is Becca's
folks cabin here just like what 30
minutes outside of Salt Lake City so
it's nice that little place lied all
right well we're up here at the cabin me
Tommy and Nathan did a little catch
clean and cook video where we showed you
guys how to trap cook and clean baby
deer and this is my beautiful wife doing
what she loves
[Music]
and our against you I go up on the
four-wheeler again you guys having fun
yeah you want to go faster
a bear is gone and scraped scrape the
tree here's his claw marks on this side
and his claw marks on this side and
these he marked his territory
look at this view guys look at this not
too shabby huh
oh look at that go ahead make a wish -
dummy is huge look at the size of those
seeds
[Music]
all right guys all right get buckled up
in there you bake it did you have a good
time Oh your nose is dirty too let's
brush your nose well we're going fishing
tomorrow you excited all right I'm gonna
rig up your rods tonight all right guys
let's get you to bed guys you have a
good night's rest you eaten some
leftover pancakes all right let's go
fishing guys let's do this
this was short here we are
Salem Lake in Utah and we're gonna do a
little fishin this is a place it's
really nostalgic for me and Rebecca when
we were college students at BYU we used
to come down here and picnic and study
and fish Becca and her parents might
come and join us and do a little
picnicking later but we're just gonna
relax and have a good time there's a
little bit of everything in this lake
there's carp there's catfish there's
bass there's pan fish is trout I'm
actually gonna do a catfish and carp
video here so oh if you check out my
other channel the catfish and carp
YouTube channel I'm gonna do a fishing
video just with the fishing right here
big old carp right there feeding data
did you fall in already yeah you got a
bunch of bites
[Music]
come on kit whoa don't wanna get all
right hold on Holy Friday came right
there oh no wait a minute no it's not a
rainbow trout check this out
Holly mackerel what's the white bass
doing here I didn't even know they had
these in here I'll get thrown back you
guys having fun though there's Tommy
warming up in the Sun there's Nathan's
just doing whatever Tommy does you guys
tired are you hungry
did you use a hamburger and some ice
cream all right let's go get some food
guys feeling better well we got a little
bit of food we may eat up fill up these
little boys and then we're gonna try
some different spots around this lake
there's a little playset and swimming
hole over here maybe they that you guys
like would would like to hang out over
here in fish all right guys come follow
me that's really nice
well the kids have had a good time but
we are sunburned and tired and it is
time to go home because we need to pack
we're leaving for Las Vegas than Japan
tomorrow morning's wait I'm looking for
Nathan has anyone seen Nathan
where Nathan Nathan cut his foot running
around at the park so I'm going to carry
him around for the rest of his life
because he doesn't want us to touch it
or put a bandaid on it or clean it I'm
wearing a Nathan it's the latest fashion
everyone's gonna be doing it this year
well guys it's late and as you can see
I'm still not packed but tomorrow
morning we're getting a car and saying
goodbye to Utah and say hello to part
two of our world tour video so stay
tuned guys we'll see you tomorrow
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
want to see part two of our 2018 World
Tour where we go to Vegas and shoot big
guns and drive fast cars make sure to
check out this video I'll put a link in
the description and I'll put a link to
all of the parts of this 2018 world tour
thanks for watching guys have a great
day